hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
a few people had requested that i do
some uh
cable reviews and uh fortunately i've
done some
so i thought i
covered this interesting high-end cable
um
by audioquest called the audioquest wind
uh got it over here um
this unusual cable it actually has a
battery
72 volts a bunch of little cells in
series generates
72 volts and that voltage then goes to
one side of the connector and then the
wire
goes through the cable but doesn't
connect to anything at the other end
what it generates is uh unknown
because you need to complete a circuit
for current to flow
and if you have a battery where one end
isn't connected to
the other end no current flows and no
electricity flows and
you know they've got a patent on this so
it is unique but whether it does
something or not we'll have to measure
at any rate the reviews online
yeah but let's go through it uh in
detail
uh references always have free cable uh
you just grabbed in my box of 3b
cables i've gotten over the years and
plug one in and
i'll call the generic free cable
somebody asked what it was and i looked
at it it actually was made by hitachi
and apparently it got a cult following
oxygen-free and what have you
but i think it's only cost like 30
or something you can still buy it in
japan
so maybe it's a good generic cable but
30 dollars i forgot to say that uh
tell you the cost of this cable this
cable for a pair at one meter
is 2 300 no that's not a typo
2 300 for two of these
by the way the owner donated this to me
that's why i still have it
so let's go down we want to compare to
see if this cable does
something better than a generic cable so
let's go ahead and do that
i've got my audio precision generating a
2 volt sine wave
at 1 kilohertz roughly 1 killers
audio precision has a sine wave
generator that's world class
it is extremely low distortion and you
can see this on the right
where it only has a tiny tiny tiny
little blip in here at 2 kilohertz
that's
down 100 minus 155 db or so
remember threshold of hearing is minus
115
115. so on the left over here this is
where
the best case hearing or you're in a
dead silent room
at one kilohertz or two killers you can
hear so we're way down here
we do see a little blip in here which is
60 hertz mains
uh interference hum if you will uh not
an issue not audible because it's well
below our
threshold here i'll come back to this
little little layer
a little later so this is our
one meter generic cable let's plug in
the audioquest wind
what do we see nothing's changed on the
right hand side of this graph on the
left side
some little change in here we actually
have a new spike but didn't have
kind of curious uh supposed to make
things better seems to have made it
worse
and this 60 hertz maintenance has
actually uh gone up
gotten worse let's ignore that for now
everything else is the same voltage is
the same distortion's the same
same frequency down to i don't know six
decimal five decimal places is still the
same so
it absolutely positively did not do
anything
so i thought that i play a cruel joke on
this dbs thing
if the design is is around and this is
directional obviously because as i said
the cable connects to one end and not
the other
to this battery thing so it would reason
that if it does something in that
direction if you reversed it it
should do the be worse or
it loses benefit well it does nothing
same 2.0 1 volts same distortion same
everything
same new spikes we didn't have before
same distortion everything
no difference whatsoever so at this
point you can be confident that this dbs
thing does nothing
useful whatsoever with respect to noise
floor
with respect to distortion with respect
to amplitude
frequency nothing's changed in in that
regard
with respect to dbs now tonality is
determined by frequency response if a
cable has a filter on it that rolls off
the highs
some cables do have passive components
in there um
that would change tonality so let's
measure that and when i say measure i
mean really really really measure we go
up to 200 kilohertz
this is 10 times harder than our best
case
more or less best case high frequency
most of us in my age are way down here
well below 20 kilohertz but let's go up
to 200 kilohertz let's figure
that these uh wealthy audiophiles that
probably are later in age and to have
money to buy this kind of thing
maybe they have preserved their hearing
and they can hear up to
two other killers here we see that the
audio precision when it's in its
loopback mode which means
just a relay turns on with no cable
essentially
and a generic cable and autoquest when
all three of them
land on top of each other in a very
zoomed
vertical scale of only one db above one
dv below
so these are really tiny tiny variations
in here
threshold of audibility is probably half
a db here but still
there's just no difference so we have
proven beyond the shadow doubt that this
thing cannot improve
increase base or lower base or increase
treble or increase mid-range
it cannot change the tonality of any
tone between 10 hertz and 200 kilos
it absolutely cannot it is impossible
for it to do that because if it can do
it
it would show up in this test very
sensitive test
but let's go back on this noise issue
that bothered me um let's
plug in the generic cable and then also
the
uh a request wind cable but turn off our
generator sine wave generator so the
analyzer now is just reading the noise
that's
from the analyzer itself and whatever
maybe generated by the cable and we see
curiously
that the uh generic cable
has lower noise in here um around
60 hertz and around 180 hertz
now 180 hertz is not a random thing it's
three times the frequency of 60 hertz
and it could be odd harmonic of of that
60 hertz
so i wanted to figure out what the
source of this was
and as i was testing i noticed if i
moved this cable around
that this measurement changed so i
thought well i wonder if it's picking up
noise from
the rest of the equipment that's in here
a lot of sources of interference
these cables are supposed to be shielded
but you know there's no
you know 100 100 shielding so
i thought i'd make a test case for a
more
uh exaggerated case where we can see the
difference
and what i did was that i took an ac
transformer these are
little adapters that come with some of
your audio gear and
i plugged in an extension cord to the
end of this so i could then move this
around as a wand
and i brought this next to the
generic cable and i brought it then next
to the uh
autoquest wind cable to see whether they
pick up
noise interference uh inductively
magnetically through the air
so i'm not making any physical
connection to anything i'm literally
just bringing that plastic case near a
cable
that transformer in there is generating
a magnetic field
so it can induce if you will the mains
uh
spectrum onto the cable if it's not
perfectly shielded
so i've got the previous two graphs
there in dashed lines
but when i bring in that cable obviously
let's focus on a generic cable in blue
we do induce more noise as i said
there's no such thing as a perfect
uh uh isolation if you will from
that kind of magnetic field that's quite
strong and so we go from this dashed
line at the bottom uh
to you know 10 or 15 db higher noise
for the generic cable and blue but look
at what happens with audi quest wind
which is the dash red just by itself
sitting in the air
to want to hook up bring the transformer
close to it
he shoots way the heck up there look at
how much higher the amplitude is
we're not talking we've gone up to 100
db from
original which was around minus
145 or so so some 50 to 60 decibels
worth of mains has been picked up
by this 2400 cable supposed to be
shielded
shielded properly you shouldn't do this
at all it should be as good
as the generic cable and uh
you might say why are all these other
things in there well the the power
company
sends you a sine wave 60 hertz but that
sine wave actually has distortion uh
and those distortions have harmonics in
them and those harmonics show up
as this series of peaks that you see uh
now any power supply that you use in
your audio equipment first thing it does
filters all this stuff once it converts
to the dc so
don't worry about this uh being an issue
with
your equipment um but in here for this
cable
it is it's picking up noise i mean it's
simple test
so the question is you know why is the
company
you know making this claim down here
that it has a
six layer noise dissipation system a six
layer
you think wow it should be much better
than my generic cable
yet we're finding the exact opposite
thing
i said whoa you know maybe they're right
well if they're right
they should make a measurement like this
and post it it's not hard
it's not it what was difficult about
making this measurement
anybody could make this measurement show
do they show this
absolutely not we can go to their
website and
you see all the claims in here you see
any measurements in here
you do not you see any graphs you do not
you don't see any specs
you do not nothing in here other than
14 paragraphs about wind and hug
the rule wind has played in ancient
greek and what have you
spare me the story i want to know if you
said lord's
noise where's where's the lord noise
it doesn't exist but people say well
there's a
trivial test you're only testing with
one tone music has many tones and
so fine let's measure that nice thing
about
testing cables is that the volume
doesn't change so we don't have to level
match anything
and i used a very high performance
system for testing i use the
my rme ada2 fs stack which is a thousand
dollar professional deck
people say somebody wants to say that's
not good rme equipment is used to
produce the music you listen to
so if you think that's no good your
music no good
and i hooked it up to a topping a 90 for
as a audio amplifier which is a
world-class
instrument-grade headphone amplifier and
then i hooked it up to a thousand dollar
um massdrop ether cx headphone
and i did an a b test there was
absolutely no difference whatsoever that
i could detect and i went back and forth
now somebody buys the 2400 cable takes
it home as i've explained in previous
videos when you hook it up and you
listen and pay attention to what you're
hearing you will hear new detail but i
guarantee you that new detail
was not new it was always there and once
that
placebo effect wears off and
it will sound just like it always did
and that's one of the reason you find
high-end audio files constantly is
searching for one tweak after the other
they that initial effect wears off and
then they go get some new and that false
set of
ah it sounds better lasts a while and
then that goes away and then the next
week and next week but that's
the plan of the topic so anyway
our conclusion here simple objectively
this cable
is worse it's got one simple job to do
take a signal from this point take it to
the other point and don't pick up noise
while you do that
we need a shielded cable because this
distance is relatively long as circuits
go and
it could pick up act like an antenna and
pick things up
uh and indeed this one is a mains
antenna
so or whatever is around it it is happy
to pick those up
now fortunately threshold of hearing is
very high in low frequencies
that's why you're not going to hear harm
or noise with this in practice
but it is generated objectively and
that's bad that's bad in a 10 cable
and certainly bad at this price point
okay so hope you like this video uh
in the comments tell me if you want more
of these controversial videos
or you want me go back to doing uh some
more
uh plane reviews and i've got a bunch of
new products to test and
i could be doing those as well as these
okay
see you in the next video bye